ja wir berichten hier ja regelmäßig über
den hyper lob von elon musk jetzt gibt
es neuigkeiten in diesem bereich denn
ein staatskonzern in china will einen
eigenen hyper lob entwickeln der mit
achtung 4000 kilometern pro stunde rast
der name hyper flight ihr habt euch
dieses thema whatsapp gewünscht und
bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen weg zu
dieser krassen idee wie genau soll diese
transporttechnik funktionieren und wie
realistisch sind die pläne aus china das
alles und noch viel mehr natürlich jetzt
sind wir zu dem science fiction herzlich
willkommen zunächst einmal sollen die
geplanten fliegenden züge in einer
luftröhre mit 1000 kilometern pro stunde
wichtige städte in china verbinden
passagiere könnten dann in 30 minuten
die 1100 kilometer von peking nach wuhan
zum beispiel in central china reisen
doch schon in naher zukunft sollen dann
auch internationaler trassen entstehen
mit unglaublichen 4000 kilometern pro
stunde soll das projekt hyper flight
dann in richtung westen und auch nach
europa ausgebaut werden das alles melden
die staatliche nachrichtenagentur kuna
und die zeitung china morning post aus
hongkong im vergangenen jahr der plan
kommt von chinas staatlichem
raumfahrtkonzern china aerospace science
and industry coporation k sieg demnach
soll mehr als 20 chinesische und
internationale forschungsgruppen an
diesem projekt arbeiten und in china
werden solche entwicklung mit viel
höherem druck vorangetrieben als im
westen hier muss ihnen masia sie sogar
zum teil gegen widerstände durch trinken
ja 4000 kilometer pro stunde das ist
schon echt der absolute wahnsinn ich
hätte euch mal vor die
höchstgeschwindigkeit von airbus 380
liegt bei 1000 20 kilometern pro stunde
und die der boeing 787 bei 9 154
kilometern pro stunde
die transporttechnik soll wohl ähnlich
wie beim heimflug von spacex chef elon
musk funktionieren darüber berichten
welche ja regelmäßig der würde bei den
angeblichen höchstgeschwindigkeiten von
4000 kilometern pro stunde galt
allerdings wirken wie ein bummelzug
genau wie der hyper lob soll der hyper
flight in einer weitestgehend luftleeren
röhre unterwegs sein so dass der
luftwiderstand reduziert werden oder
fast keine rolle mehr spielt dadurch
dass sich der geplante fliegen
dazu per magnetschwebetechnik fortbewegt
entsteht keine reibung in dem
offiziellen statement des technischen
leiters markt heißt es half life wird
die transportzeit zwischen städten
verkürzen witterungseinflüssen trotzen
und den verbrauch fossiler brennstoffe
vermeiden
er repräsentiert die zukunft der
transport der beschleunigungs und
bremsvorgänge seien darauf ausgelegt
dass die passagiere es ohne probleme
aushalten
doch das projekt wirft zahlreiche
ungelöste fragen auf wie kann man diese
technik erdbebensicher machen
wie lässt sich die sicherheit der 1000
und mehr kilometer lange vakuumröhren
sicherstellen
wie lässt sich ein dermaßen schneller
zug schnell und sicher abbremsen zu
diesen fragen und anderen technischen
schwierigkeiten allerdings gibt es keine
offiziellen aussagen
die pläne sind also bislang mehr als
wahre die chinesen selbst jedenfalls
äußern sich auf sozialen plattformen
durchaus kritisch denn darüber haben wir
ja auch schon berichtet chinas städte
sind vollgestopft mit autos dann kommt
kaum voran und der smog führt zu einigen
tools fans deswegen fragen sich viele ob
es nicht andere drängendere baustellen
in den staugeplagten städten gäbe könnte
die regierung zuerst mal ideen
entwickeln um die nervige stausituation
zu lösen
ich brauche eine stunde um von der
fünften zur dritten umgehungsstraße zu
fahren ja das heißt so in einem user
postings peking wenn ihr als erstes
neues zu diesem thema zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch
hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und
themen wie dieses hier vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
genau glocke vergessen wie geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hyper
loop rekord durch deutsches team
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran